bases are loaded
so all three getting on base and that's
going to bring up the guy that you
really
want to avoid as you do in this
situation
and that's juan soto and he struck him
out
he fooled him i mean that's a peterson
6-6 240 but he's not dustin
he's not throwing blazing fastball howie
kendrick steps in still bases loaded now
one out
two and two bases still loaded
and botched on the mound but the out is
made and a run scores
so second and third nationals get on top
first
all told though like i'm thinking cliff
this could have been much he kicked that
down
the ankle hit hard left field going back
long way to go no a sensational grab
jeff mcneal has it slamming against the
wall
wow that was a great play mcneil
obviously shaken up
slammed into that wall hard fully
extended
to brace himself still able to hold on
to the ball
possible game-changing catch that would
have been two runs coming in
easily he knows he's i guess done
he has been good in the outfield this
would be a major major loss
for this team austin voth getting ready
to go for the nationals bottom of the
first it'll be nimo
jd davis and then we don't know 3-1
lifted toward the gap and that falls in
base hit
edam collects nemo already at second
base
you can see he's running you see that
aaron throw he makes you make mistakes
as a defender right here's dominic smith
5.95
short sample so far but off to a good
start yeah hit a home run yesterday 411
feet
and i think you know he and alonzo went
back to back when they homer yesterday
and if the mets are going to be good if
that offense is going to be cooking
that's that's what you're going gonna
see
into center field michael taylor going
back and that travels out it's gone
wow easy power for dominic smith 422
feet on that one
doubled up by 11 after yesterday good
energy from the mets
missed and the bases are loaded and they
will be loaded
to pete alonso
oh wow just missed according to carlos
torres
both wanted that so did david the mask
comes down
what do you want from me i think well i
think if i'm you know
i think we want to strike out out he
goes david martinez tossed
oh so was it one of the nationals
players who were sitting in that area
that's giraffes
yeah that's true steven strasberg was he
tossed
strasbourg's got an interesting angle
because he's sitting in the stands over
there as opposed to in the dugout right
strasbourg's up there yeah yeah he
tipped the cap and off he goes that's
not what he did initially
3-2 they're still loaded
oh he struck him out on that one oh come
on you deserve one of them
no that's the same thing if that's
justice that's what
that one actually was lower you take it
out of umpire's hands
nito hits this ball hard to left field
and
that is gone big shot by tomas nito
and the mets have a 3-1 lead nito in for
his defense
makes the error and then hits a two-run
shot 106
miles per hour on that and just lifted
that ball traveling well
he only threw 47 a third innings in the
minor
before today in his career bouncing why
could forto and romero not going to get
there in time portal beats it out
tomas nito steps in against seth romero
now with the bases loaded and there is
nito
vito puts this into left field puts a
charge into that and out it goes another
home run
grand slam tomas nido needle
breaks it open for the mets well they
weren't hitting with runners in scoring
position
well until yesterday yesterday and they
slept quick right they game at the night
game
the mets coming into this series were
sixth in weighted runs created plus as a
team
lifted into center and lifted out of the
park juan soto home run
435 feet inside out seven
two juan soto continues
to crush the ball oh wow
hughes recovers and makes the play i'm
sorry john but we had a dangerous
situation there
hughes the other day was the one who got
kind of stuck in the grass and made a
divot in front of the mound
as drupal cabrera's had a good day again
he's over two see how the offer to the
result static cliff are you talking our
language
too oh and he took something off at 91
and he struck him out outstanding job by
edwin diaz
two on for adam eaton two outs here in
the night nationals again
down to their last strike brock a strike
away again
right back at him and the mets win
and the mets even up this series a lot
of power from the mets a lot of clutch
hitting